c'est un pedro castillo tout sourire est
accompagné de sa femme qui apparaît au
balcon du siège de son parti perd ou
libre et chers compatriotes j'ai le
coeur ouvert pour chacun d'entre vous
dans ma poitrine
il n'y a pas de rancoeur pas de
différence comme il se doit
nous sommes des compagnons et des frères
qui savent que le pérou est toujours
premier quelques minutes plus tôt le
candidat de la gauche radicale est
proclamé vainqueur de l'élection
présidentielle par le président du jury
national des élections
aujourd'hui nous sommes très heureux
parce que le peuple a gagné le pérou a
gagné les rêves de milliers de milliers
de paires vient en gagner aujourd'hui
nous célébrons parce que tout ce mois ci
nous sommes restés devant le jury des
élections nationales pour exiger que
notre vote soit respectée une annonce
qui vient clore des semaines de suspense
après un scrutin particulièrement serré
le 6 juin dernier lors du deuxième tour
de l'élection présidentielle pedro
castillo est déjà donné vainqueur avec
52 12 % des voix contre 49,87 % des
suffrages à sa rivale la candidate de la
droite populiste keiko fujimori
mais la fille de l'ancien président
alberto fujimori qui purge une peine de
25 ans de prison pour corruption et
crime contre l'humanité
conteste les résultats et accuse de
fraude son adversaire conséquence des
semaines durant des milliers de
péruviens descendre dans les rues
manifestants pour l'un ou l'autre des
deux candidats à la présidentielle
peu avant l'annoncé des résultats
définitifs
keiko fujimori fait finalement volte
face et annonce qu'elle reconnaîtra la
victoire de son adversaire
ainsi comment cool et je vais
reconnaître les résultats car c'est ce
qu'exige la loi et la constitution que
j'ai juré de défendre mais je ne me
rendrais pas aux élèves
roland est nommé why are in livre
j'appelle les péruviens à ne pas baisser
les bras et à mettre en oeuvre une
défense démocratique
le pérou a besoin de toutes les forces
sociales et politiques
unis dans la grande tâche d'arrêter le
communisme le défendre la liberté de la
presse et de préserver la démocratie
defender la liberté des princes et
préfère avoir la democracia keiko
fujimori faux d'immunité présidentielle
risquent désormais 30 ans de prison
visé par une enquête pour des
pots-de-vin présumés lors de ses
campagnes présidentielles de 2011 et
elle a déjà effectué 16 mois de
détention préventive
pedro castillo prendre à lui ses
fonctions le 28 juillet jour de
l'expiration du mandat du président
intérimaire francisco agace ti